and now the nominees for Best
Documentary Short subject crisis hotline
veterans press one
Ellen gusenberg Kent and Dana Perry
Joanna
Aneta capatch our curse tomash Levinsky
and machi a sit-ski the rebirth la barca
Gabrielle Sarah Arguello White Earth J
Christian Jensen and the Oscar goes to
crisis hotline a veterans press day Alan
Duesenberg Kent and Dana Mary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you make this look easy oh my god we
want to thank the dedicated people at
the crisis line and everywhere who care
for veterans as if their own lives
depended on it this immense incredible
honor really goes to the veterans and
their families who are brave enough to
ask for help we want to thank the
Academy the visionaries Sheila Nevins
who backed us all the way HBO
Jackie Glover Jeff Bart's our incredible
crew done Jake mom dad and Dana Perry
okay I also like to thank the Academy I
had to write this down so I don't forget
my children's names my family and my
husband Hart Perry my children Nicholas
Michael Perry and I want to dedicate
this to my son Evan Perry we lost him to
suicide we should talk about suicide out
loud this is for him thank you